hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we have a little bit of a special
video that I've been cooking up for the
past couple weeks during this event and
basically I decided for this video to
show some highlights of what it would be
like if we got ezio and Cesare a to
fight each other or Cesare at four keep
forgetting his name but for those two
commanders to fight each other in the
new event game-mode that came with the
Assassin's Creed collab and might I add
this was a [ __ ] to pull off I tried for
an hour and I ended up getting a 1/32
recording out of all of that so that was
pretty dumb so I decided this is some
[ __ ] and I called up some friends to
help from the discord shout it to Barney
shine and good fellows good fellows I
believe is one of spliced mods and his
streams and Barney and shine are my mods
from my streams and they're also very
nice people very helpful great guys as
well I called them up to do this for
view 4 so that we can eventually
hopefully get some clips and me now try
to kill myself doing this recording
characters that are very useful for this
could be Raider shaman warlord seemed to
work the best because of their GB throat
distance and stuff like that so we ended
up using characters like that and then
sometimes even when we did do that the
commander would either fight you or run
away if the commander fight to you're
fine but if the commander runs away he
would do that the entire time even if he
is taking damage meaning that the
attempt was a bust because he won't do
anything and he won't fight the opposing
commander thus making that clip
completely useless and meta admin these
level 3 bots bro [ __ ] these BOTS
and it wasn't even only the bots the
amount of times that I got close myself
and even with these three guys the
amount of times that we were so close to
getting into it yet we failed was
abysmal but after a hour or so in
multiple different games of getting
through this we finally found out that
we believe that River four is one of the
best Maps to do this for since the area
is very wide open and I'll show you
example of one of the very intense
fights between Cesare and Ezio and I use
the word intense very loosely you'll see
why
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that [ __ ] was intense wasn't it
almost rivals the McGregor and
mayweather UFC fight not really though
but that was one of the few instances we
did get to get those intense fights I'll
show you the rest now there is no audio
in this I did not decide to record audio
I was not having it with this event at
all but yeah you'll enjoy some very
chill lo-fi music in the background if
you want to know the song it's always in
the description of every one of my
videos what that guys like to view do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes leaks all that stuff as well
as doing some quirky videos like this
enjoy the rest of the silly video let me
know what you guys think and peace out
enjoy the clips
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't [ __ ] run away from me
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]